[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal um details
wolf und marietta slomka
die bundesregierung stellt zwei
milliarden zusätzlich für militärhilfen
bereit davon soll mehr als die hälfte an
die ukraine gehen geld statt panzer
sozusagen
derweil die ukraine den 51 kriegstag
hinter sich gebracht haben was sie denn
diese lenski zog letzte nacht eine
bittere bilanz dessen was seinem land
widerfahren ist auch sagte er er habe in
den 50 tagen viele politische führer auf
eine andere art gesehen er habe
großzügige große großzügigkeit bei denen
gesehen die nicht reich sein oder
entschlossenheit bei jenen die von
anderen nicht ernst genommen worden sein
er habe aber auch politiker gesehen die
sich so verhielten als hätten sie keine
macht wenn er damit wohl meinte zur
aktuellen lage in der ukraine ein
bericht von
malen als therapie um den krieg für
einen augenblick zu vergessen lemberg im
westen der ukraine
die jungen frauen und mädchen sind vor
den bomben am anderen ende ihres landes
hierhin geflüchtet ein stück normalität
für sie in einem land in dem seit
nunmehr 51 tagen nichts mehr normal ist
ich habe viele gefühle seitdem der krieg
begonnen hat vor allem natürlich angst
ich denke hier kann ich wieder ein wenig
ich selbst sein ohne an diese schlechten
gefühle zu denken
unterdessen heulen in kiew am morgen
erneut die sirenen luftalarm die lage in
der hauptstadt trotz des russischen
abzugs angespannt vergangene nacht nimmt
das russische militär eine
rüstungsfabrik in der nähe von kiew
unter beschuss zerstört nach eigenen
angaben produktionsstätten für lang- und
mittelstreckenraketen
hier leben doch menschen da oben in dem
stockwerk war ein arbeiter es ist ein
wunder dass er überhaupt überlebt hat
der angriff auf die fabrik offenbar eine
reaktion auf den untergang des
russischen kriegsschiffs moskva den das
russische verteidigungsministerium
mittlerweile bestätigt hat um weitere
angriffe auf den großraum kiew würden
folgen heißt es erstmals seit beginn der
invasion soll russland auch
langstreckenraketen eingesetzt haben der
ukrainische präsident selensky hier
heute bei einer kabinettssitzung dankte
seinen landsleuten in der nacht und
spielte dabei auch auf das gesunkene
schiff an die stupa
dankte ihnen die gezeigt haben dass die
russische luftfahrtwerte ist obwohl
russland zig milliarden dollar
ausgegeben hat denen die gezeigt haben
dass russische schiffe nur noch auf den
grund gehen können
derweil gibt es auch heute wieder tote
und verletzte im osten der ukraine
die versorgungslage der zivilbevölkerung
wird immer katastrophaler die angst vor
einer russischen großoffensive wächst
auch ostern werden die waffen wohl nicht
schweigen
dunkles meister ist für uns in kiew
dominique letzte nacht haben wir eben
gesehen hat es dort ja wieder schwere
explosion gegeben wird befürchtet dass
kehrt jetzt auch wieder verstärkt zum
ziel wird
ja zumindest haben dass die russischen
streitkräfte
angekündigt hier gerade vor einer
viertelstunde haben die sirenen auch
noch mal geheult wir haben das gestern
morgen 4 gab es diesen diesen
luftangriff ja außerhalb der stadt in
der nähe des flughafens wir selbst haben
das hier in der innenstadt nicht
mitbekommen aber wir haben heute morgen
noch mit vielen menschen gesprochen in
kiew die doch besorgt sind die angst
haben die auch sagen sie trauern putin
nicht kiew hat ja in den letzten tagen
auch ein etwas ruhe erlebt die menschen
konnten wieder raus sind auch menschen
zurückgekommen in die stadt und die
befürchtung ist natürlich groß dass es
wieder raketenangriffe auf die
hauptstadt gibt und hat damit ja auch
gedroht mit der begründung dass die
ukraine angeblich russisches territorium
angegriffen habe in der stadt bergen
ja das ist richtig es geht um einen
angeblichen vorfall gestern so zumindest
sagen dass die russen dass die ukraine
dort einen angriff einen luftangriff
durchgeführt haben muss sollte auch
verletzte gegeben haben die ukrainische
seite wiederum verneint dass man kann
das von unabhängiger seite nicht prüfen
es könnte aber natürlich ein vorwand
sein um eine ausweitung an
militärmissionen die wir bisher aktuell
vor allen dingen im osten und im süden
der ukraine stattfindet vielleicht auch
zu begründen man muss schon auch das
sagen auch beobachter hier in kiew sehen
dass dieser verluste dieses
schlachtschiffes der schwarzmeerflotte
doch eine große schmach ist für vladimir
putin und er wird vermutlich in
irgendeiner form darauf reagieren
nach kiew
und dann fahren wir jetzt nach jerusalem
an diesem karfreitag zur großen kreuzweg
prozession
entlang der via dolorosa
konnten dieses jahr erstmals wieder
ausländische pilger und touristen nach
jerusalem kommen wegen der korona
pandemie hatte israel ja zwei jahre lang
seine grenzen geschlossen gehalten doch
nicht nur für christen ist heute ein
heiliger tag heute begann auch das
jüdische pessachfest und muslime begehen
den fastenmonat ramadan all diese
religiösen feierlichkeiten wurden in
jerusalem leider wieder überschattet von
gewalt tom pollock berichtet ein
großaufgebot von sicherheitskräften und
der polizei wer heute in die altstadt
von jerusalem unterwegs war konnte es
nicht übersehen ob in kleinen nischen
vor geschäften auf wichtigen zugängen
oder auf der marschroute der gläubigen
die auf der via dolorosa gemeinsam an
den kreuzweg jesu erinnerten polizei zum
schutz der einheimischen touristen und
pilger die gekommen sind obwohl nach den
anschlägen der vergangenen wochen
weiterhin die höchste sicherheitsstufe
gilt auch wenn manchmal das mulmige
gefühl mitreißt wir haben also schon so
ein bisschen bammel sind jetzt auch
abends dann immer er drin gewesen und
gar nicht mehr bekommt er das hier in
jerusalem ballett mit also wenn was ist
wir hatten jetzt keine angst erst mal
war das so interessant wie diese
konstellation ist gleichzeitig hammer da
gleichzeitig
feierlichkeiten wie sich das sie
zusammen mit
ramadan besser und ostern dass die
feiern dieses jahr gleichzeitig
stattfinden hat die spannungen noch
erhöht das die sorge vor neuer gewalt
nicht unbegründet ist zeigte sich am
frühen morgen der freitag war wenige
stunden alt als auf dem tempelberg die
lage eskalierte unter tausenden
muslimischen gläubigen sollen etwa 100
randalierer gewesen sein sagen
israelische behörden als antwort darauf
sei israels polizei auf das gelände
vorgerückt mehr als 150 palästinenser
und drei israelische polizisten wurden
verletzt scharfe kritik übten
palästinenser-gruppen sie sehen mit dem
vordringen auf ihr heiligtum eine rote
linie überschritten israels regierung
jedoch beschwichtigt
wir arbeiten daran die dinge am
tempelberg und in ganz israel zu
beruhigen gleichzeitig sind wir
vorbereitet auf jede szenario
ruhig blieb das szenario heute nach den
ausschreitungen am morgen für
kirchenvertreter hat der heutige tag
deswegen eine besonders wichtige
botschaft
wir beten für den frieden auch in diesen
schwierigen zeiten in diesen wichtigen
heiligen tagen für uns christen wir
beten dafür und bitten um frieden
rund 30.000 touristen erwartet israel in
der zweiten aprilhälfte vor allem wegen
der religiösen feiertage die lage aber
bleibt angespannt und die verunsicherung
wächst ob nach den ausschreitungen heute
die gewalt weiter eskalieren könnte
in rom hat der papst den traditionellen
kreuzweg zelebriert auch erstmals wieder
öffentlich damit beginnen die
nachrichten von heinz wolf nach zwei
jahren corona pause können zum ersten
mal wieder zahlreiche gläubige dabei
sein im kolosseum in rom bei dem
kreuzweg mit papst franziskus werden die
14 stationen des leidenswegs christi
nachgestellt die zeremonie begann vor
gut einer halben stunde an einer station
soll das kreuz von 2 in rom lebenden
frauen getragen werden von denen die
eine aus der ukraine stammt und die
andere aus russland
die friedensbewegung hat ihre
ostermärsche und kundgebungen heute
fortgesetzt in chemnitz gingen rund 150
menschen auf die straße unter dem motto
für frieden für abrüstung für eine welt
ohne kriege zogen sie durch die stadt
dabei verurteilten die demonstranten den
russischen angriffskrieg aber auch wie
es hieß eine imperialistische
machtpolitik der nato die meisten
veranstaltungen sind für samstag und
sonntag geplant
der gipfel der aktuellen corona welle
ist laut robert-koch-institut klar
überschritten zu ostern sei jedoch
trotzdem vorsicht und
verantwortungsvolles verhalten wichtig
aktuell liegt die bundesweite sieben
tage incidents bei 1000 1,5 innerhalb
eines tages wurden 156
1864 neue fälle registriert
18 1399 weniger als vor einer woche
212 todesfälle kamen hinzu
in südafrika werden immer noch mehr
opfer der unwetterkatastrophe in der
küstenprovinz kwazulu natal gefunden
fast 400 tote werden inzwischen gemeldet
und die einsatzkräfte suchen weiter nach
dutzenden vermissten
gleichzeitig bereitet sich die region
nach behördenangaben auf weitere fluten
und evakuierungen vor denn für das
wochenende werden erneut heftige
regenfälle erwartet
wer heute mit dem auto in den
osterurlaub oder zum verwandtenbesuch
aufgebrochen ist der wurde auf vielen
strecken ausgebremst auf der autobahn 1
ging es sowohl richtung norden als auch
richtung süden nur langsam voran auch
wegen so manche baustelle
viel geduld brauchten reisende vor allem
am gotthardtunnel in der schweiz
zeitweise staute sich der verkehr hier
auf 22 kilometern
und der blick auf die wetteraussichten
in der südhälfte ist es morgen anfangs
noch stärker bewölkt und am alpenrand
gibt es vereinzelt schauer sonst wird es
sehr sonnig 8 bis 18 grad an den
ostertagen scheint verbreitet die sonne
ab dienstag werden die wolken dichter es
bleibt aber trocken
ein bild das sich nicht nur den
franzosen eingebrannt hat notre dame in
flammen fassungslos mussten die menschen
in paris damals zu sehen wie ihr
wahrzeichen aus brandt auf den tag drei
jahre ist das jetzt her
emanuel kuhn sagte damals wir werden
notre dame innerhalb von fünf jahren
wieder aufbauen schöner als zuvor
heute liest der präsident sich zeigen
wie weit man bislang vorangekommen ist
aus paris christel happ er hat den anzug
gegen helm und blaumann getauscht
emanuel makro will mit eigenen augen
sehen wie es um die bauarbeiten von
madrid ansteht
wie lange brauchen sie hier werden sie
bis 2024 ganz fertig sein wir hoffen es
antwortet der gefragte es gibt wirklich
sehr viel zu tun ganz fertig werden wir
dann wohl nicht sein
im kirchenschiff ist eine art zweites
gewölbe entstanden aus gerüsten die
bögen sind abgestützt das doch gewölbe
geschützt mit einer großen plane das
blei ist fast vollständig entfernt
worden jetzt wird der stein gesäubert
es wird sehr schön die pariser werden
notre dame nicht wiedererkennen sie wird
viel leuchten
diesen tag werden die franzosen wohl nie
vergessen rotterdam brennt lichterloh
der spitz turm fällt in die tiefe das
gesamte gebäude droht zusammenzustürzen
die kathedrale hält stand ist aber
schwer beschädigt die brandursache ist
immer noch ungeklärt
marie christin löffel isst ist
architektin sie überprüft jeden stein
und entscheidet welche ausgetauscht
werden muss
das ist ein gutes beispiel das zeigt was
die hitze mit den steinen macht rosetten
balustraden gewölbe so vieles ist stark
beschädigt für die restaurierung werden
2500 tonnen kalkstein gebraucht
hier war eine fantasiefigur die
hervorragt es ist dieses geflügelte
farbe tier festgehalten auf einem foto
bald wird es originalgetreu nachgebaut
es sind übrigens nicht irgendwelche
steine sie müssen genau passen die farbe
die beschaffenheit gefunden haben die
experten sie unter anderem hier die
quader werden schon herausgebrochen sie
werden gewaschen und in form gebracht
nur die makellosen dürfen nach paris
unter dem fußboden der kathedrale gab es
vor kurzem einen außergewöhnlichen fund
ein sack vermutlich aus dem vierzehnten
jahrhundert
wir haben mit einer mini kamera ins
innere geschaut und blätter reste
gefunden vor allem rund um den kopf es
könnten buchsbaum blätter seien das
weist auf eine bestattung hin die der
sozialen elite vorbehalten
rotterdam kann immer noch überraschen
auch wenn sie noch ziemlich angeschlagen
ist
ja das war es auch schon von uns an
diesem karfreitag um 23 uhr 35 gibt es
die nächste reiht express hat uns morgan
gelernt auf wiedersehen
[Musik]